bartenders lift your lid secret
ingredient is cauliflower cauliflower
our secret ingredient what
the country's top bartenders converged
on Las Vegas to battle it out the game
create a signature cocktail using a
secret ingredient to be presented to our
esteemed panel of judges all before time
runs out
whoo welcome to America's bartender we
have three premier bartenders competing
for one place in the grand final so
let's meet them my name is Graham Rasik
I'm from Vancouver BC Canada I'm a
science background major in biology I've
got a passion for chemistry
my name is Tyler Stevens I'm from
Portland Oregon what I love about
bartending is I get so much joy and
creating a cocktail that the person in
front of me has come in just searching
for hi my name is Justin Lavin II and
I'm from Austin Texas I think the
biggest reward being a bartender is
being able to honestly put a smile on
someone's face welcome bartenders under
the lids in front of you is a secret
ingredient with that secret ingredient
you will have to make an unforgettable
gin cocktail our winner will move on to
the finals for a chance to be named
America's bartender it's now time to
reveal our secret ingredient bartenders
remove the lids
secret ingredient is cauliflower I pull
off the lid and I see raw cold
cauliflower what cauliflower our secret
ingredient crazy your time starts now
so the first thing I did was grab
something with acid that I can use to
get those cauliflower flavors out I
can't honestly said I've ever tasted a
cocktail with cauliflower if it was
cooked that's hot a whole different
element raw nearly impossible wait I
would probably go down a savory Road I
would probably look at things like the
Bloody Mary for inspiration and things
like that I needed to somehow get this
cauliflower to express itself and wanted
to construct my cocktail to bring out
those natural fatty oils in the
cauliflower but they're the best in the
country so we have to tell everybody
absolutely they they know so many flavor
profiles and this is a chance for them
to really show us what they've memorized
over the years cauliflower for the most
part is fairly passive on the palate it
actually was a nice sort of clean slate
like it is this guy is cold as a
cucumber
what is it cauliflower you're up there
you're supposed to have fun and have a
good time and you know talking a little
bit it looks really cute Justin thank
you sir these guys are their friendly
banter Tyler is a classic Tucker he'll
try and get in your head and it's
hilarious so you can see Tyler and
Justin have a lot of friendly banter
they've actually competed in other
competitions before so they're very very
well adjusted for each other's her
skills up 30 seconds bartenders 30
seconds left
crunching on time I knew that I just had
to make a balanced cocktail a cocktail
that I would want to drink and try to
highlight the flavors of Bombay Sapphire
although my drink wasn't quite to the
temperature that I wanted it to be at I
just poured amendments 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3
2 1 step away from your stations well
done guys thank you very much
bartenders I have to applaud you on a
near on impossible mission cauliflower
is not something you see every day in a
bar
Tyler tell us about your drink my drink
is called neon tiger so what we have
here is Bombay Sapphire gin Aperol for
that rhubarb flavor a little dash of
creme de peche did I did lemon juice
will suffice it and use that for of my
acid in that cocktail topped off with
just a splash of soda just so that as
you drink it you get a really lively
mouthfeel frankly this was my favorite
drink out of all of them but I I'll say
this to you is that the cauliflower in
everyone was in the picture for me it
was about the a per all the time the
garnish everything else but the the
cauliflower I never should even showed
up it wasn't even a component of thin
drink just think great job
tell us about your cocktail the cocktail
is named poor Miguel what we did here is
we took a classic gin cocktail and we
hyper diluted it using a little bit of
water that was flavored with cauliflower
and green apple peel and then we're
smoking it so smoking the cocktail you
get a little bit of smoke in that
gunflint note and I'm glad I could share
it with you thank you so much you made
it work and what you set out to achieve
you've you've done very well of that I
love the fact that Bombay Sapphire is
then I can you've used your expressions
and your different techniques to really
bring that through and highlight by
myself I'm Graham please tell us about
your cocktail the cocktails name is
canvas so a little bit of purple mousse
bitters over the top to give a bit of
aromatic I use a bit of cayenne to bring
out a sort of pepperiness from the
cocktail but then wanted to make it look
like paint splatter on the top this is
this is my art piece for you to enjoy as
far as the the strength of the
cauliflower flower flavor coming through
without a doubt you definitely capture
that well I don't get the cayenne and
the problem mousse it's a beautiful
cocktail and thank you thank you
gentlemen
fantastic job the winning drink today
was the cocktail that best highlighted
the secret ingredient with balanced
beautiful flavors texture and
imagination and the winner today going
through to our grand final with a chance
to be crowned America's bartender
is
Justin Justin's poor Miguel cocktail one
today because it balanced a highly
complex palette of flavors while still
bringing gin and cauliflower to the
forefront he's going through to define
and well done buddy congratulations
thank you I mean I'm happy that I won
but really the only thing on my mind
right now is tomorrow in the competition
I can't even really enjoy this moment
because I know that I have so much to do
want to try making this winning cocktail
at home give it a taste for more
exciting competition subscribe to the GQ
channel